what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder before
we get started
in the comments down below let me know
who is your favorite spider-man
filming has just wrapped for spider-man
3 no way home
most of the filming is now done they may
come back and do some retakes but for
the most part they got all the shots
they need and are now moving on to the
editing phase and this is great news
because this means that the chances of
us getting a trailer relatively soon
are pretty high hopefully within the
next few months
but with the ending of the filming for
spider-man no way home some interesting
things are happening that could reveal a
little bit more about the movie
including the inclusion of the
spider-burst
and of course we're specifically talking
about andrew garfield spider-man
returning in spider-man no way home and
toby maguire spider-man returning in
spider-man no way home as well
something that many many fans are truly
excited about
and today we have even more evidence to
support the theories that andrew
garfield spider-man and toby maguire
spider-man are indeed going to be in
spider-man no way home so if you are
trying to stay up to date with
spider-man no way home be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
so today we have a similar situation of
something that happened only a few days
ago
now last week andrew garfield stunt
double was apparently
on the set of spider-man no way home and
tom holland's stunt double seemingly
talked about him and mentioned that he
was on the set of spider-man no way home
as well
then only a couple of days ago there was
some merch released for the film crew
that also hinted towards the inclusion
of the spider-verse and toby maguire and
andrew garfield spider-man in the movie
as well
and today we have something that gives
us even more evidence that toby
maguire's stunt
double was on the set of spider-man 3.
with the wrapping of the filming of
spider-man no way home
george cottle one of the stunt
coordinators of the movie
posted on instagram thanking a bunch of
people who were involved with the movie
on instagram he posted a picture of the
whiteboard that said spider-man no way
home on it with all the other writings
on it the same board that was used to
reveal the official title of the film
and in the post he said that is a wrap
on one of the most incredible projects i
have ever been a part of
where do i start he then went on to
thank john watts tom holland
zendaya jacob battalon and tony revolori
he then went on to thank
his team which is the stunt team and he
said and of course
to my team i am only ever as good as the
people around me and then he went to
thank a bunch of people and one of the
persons that he thanked in this post
was chris daniels now if you don't know
who chris daniels
is he actually was the stunt double for
tobey maguire in
spider-man 2. since spider-man 2 back in
2004 he actually worked with marvel
again in black panther and an avengers
end game helping do some other stunts
for other characters who were wearing
masks and now he is apparently working
on spider-man no way home
however tom holland has his stunt double
on set we've actually seen many leaked
photos of his stunt double
and in george cuddle's post he thanks
many different stunt doubles as well
so the question now is who was
christopher daniels doing stunts
for in spider-man no way home it's not
tom holland because tom holland's stunt
double is greg townley and it's safe to
say that since so many stunt doubles
were listed
in this post other people like zendaya
or tony revolori had their stunt doubles
on set
as well if they had to do any scenes
involving them and of course it's very
interesting and coincidental that a
movie that is highly rumored to involve
the spider-verse and the return of toby
maguire has an
old tobey maguire stunt double working
on the film
it's also pretty interesting that this
comes just days after william spencer
the stunt double four andrew garfield
posted photos from the no way home set
alongside of tom holland stunt double
that were later
deleted this is all pretty coincidental
and although the spider-verse isn't yet
confirmed we do have a lot of evidence
pointing to the fact that it is going to
be happening
however we're still trying to be kind of
reserved because marvel pulled a ralph
boner on us before in one division and
we're trying not to get that pulled on
us again
so just in case it doesn't happen we're
trying to keep our expectations
kind of low however it seems like every
week there's just
more and more evidence pointing towards
the spider-verse but do me a favor and
let me know what you think is going to
actually happen
in the comments down below do you think
marvel is perhaps trolling us somehow
or do you think that this is the film
that we're actually going to get tobey
maguire andrew garfield and tom holland
all together on one screen even if it's
just for a quick
little cameo well be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
can stay up to date if i hear anything
else of course i'll do a video updating
everybody
and let me know who is your favorite
spider-man in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof